من وسط هذا الدمار هنا في منطقه مشروع بيت
لاهيه بعض العائلات يبحثون عن حياه رغم
هذا الدمار ورغم ما اصابهم في هذه المنطقه
هنا احد
العائلات تبحث تحت الركام عن الدقيق هنا
في شمال قطاع غزه رغم خطوره هذا الامر هنا
الا انهم يبحثون عن الدقيق الذي كان
متواجد فيه منزلهم قبل
قصفه لكن بسبب عدم دخول المساعدات وعدم
توفر الدقيق قاموا بالحفر في هذه المنطقه
والوصول لمكان الدقيق ويقومون لو في رمل
لو في شوك بدنا ناكله لو في حص بدنا
اخراجه
بمعاناه يعطيكم العافيه الله يعافيك ايش
بتعملوا والله احن منطول في هال الطحين في
هالدار محطوط تحت الرجم رغم الخطوره واله
الا من نطول الطحين لانه فيش مساعدات
بتمرق على الشمال والواحد محتاج بده ياكل
يشرب عنده صغار ومن هالكلام فحنا بيتنا
انهدم زي ما انت شايف وجينا بنينا خيمه
جنب البيت وقاعدين منطول الدقيق من تحت
الركام مش قادرين تشت لا والله ماحنا
قادرين
نشتريه الوضع صعب هسا في الشمال عادات
بتمرق والامور
صعبه اكبر خطر هذا احنا اللي فيه يعني لو
ضربوا دار قدام منا وهنا احنا بنيل تحت
الراده كل هذا عشان نطعم صغارنا تحت خمس
طوابق هذا العماره انت فيها هذا دار على
الرابع احنا في الدور الاول بنشتغل
تحت ان شاء الله بتدخل المساعدات والواحد
بطل يخاطر في حاله هيك يعني وربنا بفرجها
ان شاء الله الجميع والكل بصلوا
مساعداته في موت احنا في موت احنا ه الم
اعتبار في
موت في اكثر من هيك خطر ابراهيم والله ما
في انا مستعد اطعم اهلي مستعد في اليوم
اموت 6000 مره و 100 مره بس اطعم اهله
واطعم هالصغار اللي
عنده لانه احنا ناس في غزه بنموت 6000 مره
باليوم وضعه انفرد على الجميع
هذا يعني منيح بعد كل ه الدمار الواحد
متذكر وين بيته مطبخهم
[موسيقى]
يعني اذا هكذا هو المشهد هنا في شمال
القطاع في ظل عدم دخول المساعدات حتى هذه
اللحظه الى شمال غزه وعدم توفر المواد
الغذائيه الاساسيه للمواطنين للاستمرار في
الحياه هنا المواطنين يخاطرون بانفسهم من
اجل اخراج ما تبقى من تحت الركام من دقيق
انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه